And I have the pleasure of welcoming
Alex [inaudible] who is the director of
lipstick under my burger.
I'm very excited.
I've read a ton of articles about it.
I'm looking forward to seeing the movie.
She's promising to send me a link.
So I'm definitely looking forward
to seeing the movie. I'm just,
we're just going to have a dialogue
honestly and Alan Crita is gonna, uh,
answer just a few questions and
talk a little bit about the movie,
but we will give an opportunity at the
end for you guys to ask any questions as
well. Perfect. So hello,
welcome to Google. Hello.
I'm be happy to be here. Is this
your first time here? It is.
Zen.
It's such an amazing gamblers.
Yes,
you'll have to get coffee and free snacks
and all of those good things before
you do that. So first of all, I,
I definitely,
we were just chatting.
I want to extend definitely thoughts
and prayers to your family and your
community in Mumbai, India, they're
dealing with floods justice in Houston.
So definitely wanted to extend our
thoughts and prayers to your community.
Absolutely.
So I have been reading a ton of articles
and there's been so much Christ around,
uh, this awesome movie. But I would
love to just hear in your words,
what is this movie about?
White Lipstick Gunderman
burqas essentially film
about for a small down women
who lead these secrets do alliance and
they sort of searching for freedom.
So it's set in one sort of
ramshackle building, uh,
in this moment on all four
of them of different ages
and they're sort of, um, uh,
living there and they're
trying to rebel in.
I'm very small sort of visa and
the tried to fulfill their dreams.
So that's what it's about.
That's awesome. So I'm very intrigued
by the title lipstick under my Barca.
Talk about that a little bit.
Where was that inspiration from?
Lipstick on mine will come actually
the, um, uh, the title and, um,
the idea of the firm that
emerged at the same time.
So it wasn't like I am part of the data
leader and for me it's a metaphoric
title because it really
means that, uh, um, you know,
women have this while seating
desire to be free and begin sort of,
um, I mean sometimes
even if we feel that, um,
society is sort of bound
them into southern drawl,
let me think that they're not
dreaming of anything more.
The truth is that they are,
so they have like hidden desires and
wheel dreams and uh, yeah. So it's,
it's just that you can't stop women or
no matter what, you don't know what,
how many restrictions there are.
They always going to want
to like spread their wings.
Awesome.
So we were talking a little bit about the
letter you received when the movie was
practically not released or band in India.
Can you talk to us about just kind of
the verbiage and what was the meaning
around the banning
of this movie? So I know in
Indiana as a system of, um,
certification.
So if you have to have your film shown
in theaters and then you have to go to
this government body,
which is a definite with a sense of what
though it's not technically called that.
So at the end of December,
last year after the film had
started traveling to festivals,
we thought we should try to figure out
the India theatrical release and, um,
we'd ride for the census
certificate and, uh, the, uh,
the board. And what they did was they
decided to, um, not certify the film.
So we had two screenings and both times,
you know,
and it took many months and they refuse
to certify the film on the grounds that,
um,
and the fitness lady oriented and
fantasy above life and all of that.
So basically the whole idea was that
they wanted to stifle the filmmakers aids
made true mom may strongly
female point of view.
And it tells the stories of women and
then wanting to have agency over their own
lives and their bodies
in a way that I think they felt was a
threat to the patriarchal sort of order.
And I do feel that, um, that
sense of order of India, uh,
you know,
bypassing is kind of a decision.
They were functioning in a way that
they really wanted to sort of perpetuate
patriarchy because the popular
culture in India is completely molded,
uh, you know, by the
male gaze. And, um, uh,
the typical like Bollywood sort of trope
is to have item songs and women who,
uh, you know, very peripheral parts
for women. And even if you see women,
they like virginal and PR
or they're like Vampish,
um,
or they're like mottos,
but very little space for
real and ordinary women or
they're just like objects
of desire for mail fulfillment.
So it's just a very convenient sort of
way in which women have been portrayed
over the decades.
And of course that has to do with the
fact that storytelling is completely been
controlled by men forever. So, uh,
and I think like us Indian societies
also completely conditioned to consume
popular culture through the eyes of men.
So everybody celebrates the
objectification of women
without even thinking twice
about we know what is it that they're
watching and they're loving and they're
dancing to, um, which is fine as long as,
as it leased space for an
alternative point of view.
But I think what the censor board was
trying to do was to stifle any kind of
alternative point of view. So
in effect, they were saying
that, uh, you know, for a,
this Indian citizens, the only kind
of culture they should consume,
um, should be a culture that
perpetuates male domination.
And I think that is really,
really low wrong. And I
thought it was very important,
uh, for us to call them out on
this decision that the mean, uh,
which is why I decided that, you
know, whatever happens, you know,
we must release the film
and the producer of the Fed,
Mr Brick Isiah and the production company
are very, very clear that, you know,
whatever we have to do, we're going to do
when we couldn't get the film out. And,
um, so finally then we, uh,
when all this happened, um,
it was like we went through a process,
we actually went to a judicial body and
it took quite a few weeks and you know,
having hearings and
lawyers and this and that.
And finally the decision was reversed.
And after long, yeah. Battle.
So we applied for the certification at
the end of December. I got it in June,
uh, this year. And, uh, the
film released in India in July.
And just to put it in context,
normally this procedure takes about
three to four days. Wow. And it took me,
so how long does it normally take?
So what has been the response in India
since the release of the movie? Uh,
it's been very, very interesting.
It's been, um, uh, and actually the,
the thing is that because of the
most traveling to various countries,
because of like,
it was participating in various film
festivals since October last year and then
this bad thing happened.
So I think there was a lot of
conversation in the media about, um,
and on social media about
the fact that, uh, you know,
audiences and other countries are able
to access the foam but not Indians
themselves.
So there was a lot of buildup in fact,
when the release actually happened. And
I think people had all kinds of, uh, uh,
ideas and expectations from the film.
So we've,
I was quite anxious about the release,
but it's been really,
really interesting that the people
are really, uh, uh, embrace the film.
The film did really well, but I, I mean,
it's not just in terms of numbers with,
I think what the numbers represent is
the fact that they've actually so many
people who made the effort to go for a
film like this, which is a independent,
which is an independent film about women.
They actually went to the theater to see
it and lots and lots of men also went
to watch the film.
And I think a while the reactions of
most women were the reactions I got from
many,
many women who is very,
very new thing in terms of how they felt
like their stories have been told. And,
uh,
you know,
there's the stories of their mothers and
their sisters and their daughters and
their friends.
It felt very represented in that sense.
But I think for the men, it was like
some men really felt I was a sort of,
for the first time they've thought about
women like that and they've never, uh,
uh, uh, I mean there's just
haven't given it a second thought.
And they were way more
interesting experiences that
people report it. Like, uh,
you know,
some young men who went to watch the
film thinking it's just going to be a sex
fest. And then, uh, you know,
start to feel a little
irritated to begin with.
And then started understanding the
film and then got drawn into the film.
And then like this boy,
one of the boys wrote to me and was like,
he was the first person in the head over
up to start clapping when the Filbert
over, which was a very like, common
reaction that happened with a film.
Like the film would get over and
people would just get up and like start
clapping and all of that.
So I think very interesting.
And some men who went to see the film,
somebody asks him what
for them to go and see.
And they would not name lipstick and
America. They would be like, uh, you know,
we want to see like something done called,
it would be like,
where's he's a motherfucker. So it,
it's been very, very, um, interesting.
But I do think that, uh, um, you
know, from the standpoint of, um,
um, women's, um, uh, I mean the
rights for women do like of,
of women to be able to express themselves
in a country like India where there is
so much violence against women and so
much discrimination against women and we
have a popular culture that keeps
perpetuating this vicious cycle. Um,
I think the fact that lipstick and my
bill can actually reason theaters as a
huge victory because I
really did feel that, uh,
if he had not been able to release it,
it would be like,
we are seeing that it's okay, uh, for,
uh,
you know,
the sense of what to actually
muscle like 50% of the population.
You're saying that we should
get the voices of women.
So I did feel that there's,
Denise was not just about
a film releasing, but the
idea that well, you know,
if, uh, India is a country
where, uh, you know,
we are promised equality of gender,
then definitely women should be as free
to be able to tell their stories and
share their experiences.
Particularly in the context of a
country like India where there is, I've,
I mean there is such a huge disparity
between rights and opportunities between
men and women.
So when I, when I be reflecting on
the things that I've been reading,
it's really been like
stories of liberation, right?
And all women can really relate to that
front, whether black, white, Indian,
any racial or ethnic background.
What gave you the courage
to sort of tell this story,
which is really in conflict of
what the normal story quote,
normal story would be?
A in traditional Indian cinema?
No, it's been interesting that you
ask this question because uh, uh,
the sun does come from very a personal
space. I think being a woman who's,
I'm an Indian woman,
but I've been,
I feel I've been brought up with a fair
degree of privilege in terms of, uh, uh,
you know, education and no one ever
telling me that you can do this.
You can't do this, you can
go here, you can't go here.
But I still feel that, uh, you know,
there are those things that make you
feel like you're not completely free.
And I was quite preoccupied with this
idea of not feeling fully free and um,
and I thought it's so strange that
externally I don't feel like there's any
obstacle to man, you know, me
feeling completely like, uh, uh,
having like, you know,
like a, a completely free
sort of mind space in life.
So I wanted to explore this feeling
and then, then I thought the drought,
the next lower through world, um,
which is very similar to mine,
why don't explore it through mill you.
Um,
whether also external, um, uh,
obstacles to a women's freedom and where
society has like a strong hold on the
rules that women have to play.
And also where everything is not as
simple because you don't have so much
economic privilege. And I
thought, why don't I, you know,
set this in this world
and that kind of world.
And I think it was very interesting is
that it is culturally a very specific
story because it's about one neighborhood
in one small, small town in India. Uh,
but I think what's been amazing is like,
you know,
the film is going to like more than 45,
uh, film festivals and said Premiere and,
um, uh, to begin with, most
of the festivals that the
film showed at were, you know,
they will, not South Asian festivals or
anything. And it was very interesting, um,
to see that so many people from so many
different cultures and nationalities
were really connecting with a film.
Uh,
having no idea about what life is like
in South Asia. I mean, just, you know,
having a vague notion but not
having like any active engagement.
And I think that was really an eyeopener
for me, even as a filmmaker, as a writer,
and a director that, um, uh,
you know, sometimes we limit,
we think that if we are
culturally specific, uh,
we're going to alienate,
um, other cultures.
But I thought that because
it was rooted locally,
um, I think somehow, um, about
the stories are universal and in,
in that sense.
So I felt like I was quite a surprise.
There may happily surprised by,
uh,
the sort of way in which the film was a
film has been embraced by people like,
from so many different,
you know, countries,
whether it's Egypt project plan
or Sweden or, uh, you know,
it's showed in many festivals in, in
the u s as well. So I think for me,
that was very,
very interesting to see how people were
feeling a sense of even people like in
France and all where, you know, you
feel like women, um, have like, I mean,
things are not as, uh, as an input,
but like everywhere, that sense of, uh,
of ownership with the, and feeling a sense
of identification with the characters.
So I think that was
very interesting to me.
And I think that reminded me of a very,
very important thing that I think a
women across the world share bond and it
really cuts through like
every other divisions with
thing. There are so many, uh,
you know, sometimes the world
seems less a divisive place. Uh,
but I really think that there's something
though there are many specifics,
but I think there is a deeply like shared
common sort of bond across a women.
And I think, uh, yeah,
I think that's something
that really realized while
seeing people from different
countries.
What was the film?
I think it was the Hollywood insider
describe the movie as a quote,
feminist drama.
And we could probably talk about
the concept of feminism all day. Um,
but it's not something you agree with
that description being feminist drama.
Uh, I am very happy that, I think
it was the Hollywood reporter,
but like after that,
I think that was one of the first reviews
that had come out or nothing off that
many other people have described the
film as a feminist drama. And, uh,
um, I think, uh, I'm very,
I'm a very proud and I do feel the reason
you want to us sitting here and having
this conversation because
of the feminist movement.
And I feel it's because of generations of,
um,
uh,
you know,
women who fought for the right of women
to work the right to water, right,
to sort of own your own life. Um,
I don't think we can ever, um,
we can ever like forget that debt.
So I do feel that it's very important
for everybody actually to own,
uh, own the idea of feminism because
feminism for me really means,
or Oh, situation where,
uh, you know, there is,
there are equal rights and equal
opportunities for men and women.
And sometimes I do get a little, I
mean, I feel it's very important.
Like I keep feeling it's very important.
Explain to people who are like, oh,
you know, but, uh, I don't know.
I just feel it's such a strong word
and I don't believe in feminism.
I really want to like explain to them
that if you see you are not feminist or
you see,
you don't believe in feminism,
then what you're seeing as
you feel patriarchy rocks
and you feel like, you know,
patriarchy should rule the
world. It should just be
like mentioned be paid more,
you know,
they should,
women should die because of dowery
debts and women should be more or less
everything that you're seeing then is
what you're saying then is that you want
the words to be ruled by men. If you're
saying you don't believe in feminism.
So I think it's very, very, or I mean just
beyond the idea of a film or whatever.
I just feel it's very important
for men and women, um,
to really own the idea of
feminism because I feel, um, uh,
until there is a equal of the
genders, I feel, you know, like many,
many big things in the world are not going
to really change. And I feel it's, um,
I mean I feel like it's the biggest
problem in the one this inequality between
men and women because it just really
does got through like any kind of
countries,
any situation.
So I just feel that it's very
important to coming back to the film.
I'm very happy and very proud of
people. Uh, call it a feminist drama.
I feel, uh, um,
it's nice when one's own viewpoint or
as a person comes through in one's work.
Um, so I don't feel like I set out
to be like I have to make a feminist,
but I wasn't doubting it be a
feminist because of lamb. Hmm.
That's awesome.
So the word censorship came up in a lot
of my reading in preparation for our
chat and of course for me,
since censorship just means
stifling someone's voice.
So what advice would you give to
women mean it folks in the room,
folks listening to utilize and leverage
their voice even when it's times when
they're afraid or a times when
it's not going to be accepted.
What advice would you give?
What I would just say that it's very
important to not be discouraged because I
feel every force outside of you that's
[inaudible] voice is banking on your
feel. And they feel that because
of feel your back though.
And I feel if you can battle
that Phil, I mean, Oh,
I'm continue fighting.
I think that's the only way forward.
And sometimes even been in,
sometimes we may not. Uh,
but I think the most crucial
thing is to continue fighting.
And I really think they always banking
on field because you, every time I feel,
uh, whether it's, um, you know, it,
it's just that they feel that they
can threaten him and you know,
whatever in some way or the other,
they try to leverage something or the
other against you. And this some, not one,
not just in terms of censorship refilm
but censorship of books and ideas and
thoughts. So I feel that
it's very important to, uh,
to continue speaking and to continue
standing up for what one believes in two
country, voicing our thoughts. And it's,
I don't think it goes in Wayne and I feel
like every drop like makes the ocean.
Sometimes I might think that my
little fight in my, I don't know,
maybe in my classroom or in my
little workplace is not important.
But I do feel that every battle smaller,
big actually comes in the
larger scheme of things.
So I might think that it's
very small and you know,
it may affect only me and 10 other people,
but I think there's a ripple effect.
And I feel when people see
one person have that courage,
it empowers 10 others to have courage.
And when those 10 others I empowered then,
you know,
it's sort of like a ripple effect.
And I feel it also like creates
a sense of network and you know,
being able to have solidarity with other
people who might be facing such similar
issues and all of that. So I think that,
uh, it's really, really important. Also,
I feel like,
I think the one thing that I realized
when this entire thing happened is that I
was very secure in the area that I live
in a free and democratic country. And, uh,
you know, like India, so, you
know, healthy, bustling democracy.
And when, uh, the film
was, uh, uh, you know,
it was refused certification.
I think the thing the thought that
really hit me is that I didn't realize or
notice as free, you know, and I think, um,
and then I also started thinking
that, uh, so this is like,
it's been 70 years since an air became
independent. And I started thinking that,
uh, you know, this freedom
that was fought for,
uh, by many, many people in many
sacrifices with me to, you know,
get it off the British and become
free and all of that. I was like,
we have to reimagine that freedom. Like
it's not like what can we became free.
We got ourselves a great constitution
and it's all good. Like people go vote.
I just feel for every
generation you have to sort of,
we had your own battles
and reclaim that freedom.
And I realize nobody's coming and gifting
me my gender equality and my freedom
of expression in like a little bag with
a pink bow and I'll open it up. I'm like,
oh wow.
I realized that I was like,
thing is freedom is guaranteed to us by
the constitution and gender qualities or
I mean the equality between men and
women is, is guarantee to us with,
until we claim it and make it real. And
it's, and that has to be an active thing.
It's not like it's a static thing.
So I just felt that, you know,
like I can't be like India is
like this or whatever, like,
and this has happened to me over here.
If I'm an Indian citizen,
then I should try to utilize my rights
to speak up and utilize the system to get
me the freedom that I feel I'm on
because I am a citizen of this country.
So I just feel it becomes,
uh,
it needs to be a more active process
and I feel we need to keep doing this I
guess after every few years because we
otherwise we just sort of becomes like a
dead sort of a space,
which I think with cinema in India in
the sense of even living with censorship
forever and I think with Tony now
than the last like year or two years,
it's really been blowing up in everybody's
face because you realize that you
don't have to, I never given
independent and we have this, uh,
censorship system and nobody was really
like questioning it in such a big way.
But no,
I think it's just like,
it's just moving up in everyone's face
and lived in like, we do read on one date,
but I think it's up to us to
actually change the system.
What does this movie mean for girls,
young girls?
I know it's late oriented,
has sexual language and all
of those types of things.
But what do you think for our girls
who are trying to find their courage,
find their voice, all of these
things that we've been talking about,
what could this movie mean for them?
Um, I guess I would want every girl to
interpret it in her own way, but if I do,
um,
and you know,
I don't know up to her what she
sort of wants to take back from it.
But I guess if I had to sort of, um, uh,
think about it in terms of thematically,
um,
I think it's very important for
women to put themselves first.
I think as women we are constantly being
conditioned to put ourselves second,
you know,
it's always like duty forest and like
what have to do with my family falls.
What makes, I don't know.
Like, so I think that, um,
in a sense the film is also about what
happens when these four women try to put
their own desires and their own dreams
before anything else. So I feel as women,
you know, sometimes we, we don't
even realize how conditioned we are,
do not put ourselves first and never
give us, give us gift ourselves.
Was that freedom that I think
we all sort of dissolve.
And I also feel like a sister would like,
not that the film is overtly
at all about sisterhood,
but I feel like if we're
watching the film you feel like,
um, there may be so many women and I don't
know what their stories are and let me
have like the heart to embrace
them because I do feel,
I feel really want things to change.
Um,
I think women really have to sort of get
together and really support each other
for any real change to happen.
And we don't even realize it.
And something like the glass ceiling,
um,
I feel it's like boys gloves and this
whole locker room thing and the golf
course for everybody. I mean
there are ways that, um,
and the fact that, you know,
we keep saying that all
women are threatened by
other women in the workplace,
for instance. It's because women
have had such few opportunities.
And that may not even be the case,
but I feel it's also patriarchal construct
that is fed into, I had said, you know,
no woman will ever look out for you.
No one is going to give you a
helping hand because you know,
women are supposed to,
so I feel like we ourselves need to
break through like all of these myths.
And I do feel that it's
important for us to have that.
And I feel like sometimes
just share, you know, being,
being able to listen to another person's
story and giving them that kind of time
and having that sense of empathy, um,
leads to a lot of change. So I think, uh,
for me, I would feel like if you
know, for those two as well, actually,
whether it's men or women,
whoever watches a film,
I'm just feel like they can see the four
women with all their hopes and their
dreams, their laughter, their
heartbreak, the ambition, their passion.
And at the end of the two was
just feel like they do, you know,
they're friends with those people
and they actually know them.
I think my job is a flamingo
would be done after,
well you set the bar pretty
high lipstick under my burqa.
So my question is what's next for you?
And I must see that.
I wish I was like, I was so clear
it was like one next thing. But uh,
yeah,
I think I'm like in a state of confusion
because there are like two or three
things in my head,
but I must see them actually were
preoccupied by the idea of a women finding
themselves and women finding strength.
So all the stories that I'm
dabbling within my head are about,
um, you know, needs a women,
but I don't know which one
I'm going to really do for us,
but they are definitely, I
feel like I'm very, very, uh,
passionate about telling stories,
telling stories about women
from a female point of view.
And that that's what actually drives me
to make films on the way that would not
do that. So, yeah. So it's going to
be, I mean, it will be about that,
but I don't know which one I'm going
to. Well, let's see what works out.
Okay, well I definitely
want to open it up for sure.
So I'll ask you for a little
bit of a social commentary
if that's okay. Uh, so we,
I think we all know about Yarra,
a trouble with the CDFC and, uh,
we are sorry about that because
we all enjoy good cinema. Um,
so I do agree and we all know
that India does have its problems,
like with its female infanticide,
whether it's harassment
with her glass ceilings. Uh,
but do you feel India has,
you know,
made good progress for the last 70 years?
The reason why I'm asking
is now we do see, you know,
films like yours or Bar Star mom
coming out of Bali board. Uh,
the top three CEOS in India or women who
are the CEO's of nationalized banks or
banks. Um, and you know, we've had
very powerful woman, chief ministers,
prime ministers, precedent, you
know, which hasn't been achieved,
even advanced nations. Uh, so
I'm wondering if, uh, you know,
do you see that we are the
same old patriarchy are,
are we are making progress or are
there really to India is like the urban
educated India and the rural
somewhat backward India.
Um, that's a very way have a very
good question. And I must say,
I don't damn fully equipped to answer it,
but from my own,
I mean I can only express my own opinion.
Definitely things have
changed I think go once.
I mean the many more women are being
educated and many more women are um,
you know, for instance
in banking jobs, um,
and many more women in
the workforce overall. So,
and of course we've had, um,
many more female politicians.
I mean South Asia has that trend.
Um,
and earlier at an earlier time you've
had many female politicians across South
Asia compared to the Western world.
Um,
but I feel that,
um,
I wouldn't gloat over that progress
because I feel we have such a long way to
go.
And being a woman who
has grown up in India,
definitely I feel like there is
change and there is progress.
In a normal kind of way.
Um,
but have things really changed in
terms of our women still see if on the
streets,
if there's still a dowry,
is there still marital
rape is still illegal. Uh,
I mean it's not illegal in India,
so, oh, I feel we have a very, very,
or long we'd go and I don't know,
I feel like while it's good to make a
note of various things that are changing,
it's not, uh, the change. I don't
think, I mean I don't feel like posting,
I'd be really very satisfied with that
change because I feel they will be a long
way to go. And, uh, and I feel
like that is still, for instance,
even if you look at like the number
of women making films in India,
it is so minuscule compared to the number
of films that are made in the country.
And I do feel many of these
things are not specific to India.
Like the glass ceiling for instance,
is something that is a problem
across the world. Uh, you know,
sexual harassment at the
workplace and things like that.
Some things are more specific
to India, which is like, um,
you know, there's still that stigma
attached to being a widow. And, uh,
this kind of being very disheartened
when a girl child is born.
So not to say things are not changing.
They are,
but I feel not dynamically
enough, not fast enough. And in
many ways things are not changing
at all. So I do feel like, um,
um, but degree I feel like we used
to be just physical safety of,
you know, of, of women and
overall the sense of like,
even if you'll see the number of
women who actually go into any,
like the number of women who actually
enrolled in a course to study.
And then when you see like the number
of women actually pursuing that
profession, both authorities,
there's like a huge sort of drop.
And I do feel even when women
are working, it's like, you know,
it's like the Labor is not shared
in terms of the home space.
So I just feel that we have
a very, very, or, um, uh,
we have a long way to go.
And I just feel that, uh, uh,
I think I would rather see all the anon
stuff because I feel like we can sit on
those laurels and they don't.
Uh,
because even having a had a female
prime minister and having had a female
president,
it didn't change the situation and
the grass root level in terms of uh,
you know, many things. Visa,
we dilute ed educational,
the lack of nutrition for a
goals and things like that.
So I just feel that we really
do have a, um, a long way to go.
I hope I've tried to answer. And as
about doing this, I think there are many,
many Indians and there's a
really interesting country
because there's so much
diversity and everybody's
reality is different.
I do feel it's not that there
are not problematic things. Um,
[inaudible] uh,
upper middle class educated people,
I feel like even visa be gender issues,
I think that a lot of issues even
over there. So I think, yeah,
those do cut across classes as well.
You mentioned that like you have a few
projects that you're not trying to figure
out what's next. So hose, like
how was this experience like,
how has it impacted your decisions?
Like how do you kind of keep it like a,
you know, I'm not going to learn these
and this experience impact my decisions?
Like will you be more like, hey, maybe
there's a controversial subject that's,
you know, your new next project and
[inaudible] given my experience, you know,
I should just see away
from it for a while. Or,
I mean it's easier to say that it will
take for the open mind and like look at
scripts in that way.
But how is this experience like
how's it changed you in any way?
I think it's definitely or
changed me and it's grown me up.
It's been a very long and
difficult or journey to, um,
to make this film right from
the start. And, uh, yeah,
and I think that,
I think the main thing it's taught me
in life is that a do not give up because
it was really difficult even
getting the film, uh, you know,
out there in many other ways and all of
that, not just a censorship otherwise,
although it's been a very,
very long and difficult journey.
So I think, uh, uh,
it has taught me that you do not give
up because I think this feminism,
this is my second feature film.
I think my first feature film was
perhaps easier than this one. But, um,
I think the only thing that's clear to
me that I should try and focus on, make,
you know,
making the kinds of films and telling
stories that I really believe in because I
feel if I didn't believe
100% on this film,
I would not have been able to sustain
this very long journey that it's taken me
to write to the time when
I thought of the film,
do like writing and
getting it into production,
finishing and getting, you know,
getting distribution, getting released,
the wholesome shit thing.
So I think it's just reinforced the idea
that it's very important for me to have
like complete conviction in what I'm
doing because you don't know what like how
long you have to keep fighting
for, uh, for what you've created.
So it's, uh, I mean the fact that I had
100% faith and conviction in, in, in,
in the story, in the film, I
think that was a really important,
and I think that is something I
think I'm just nervous about that,
that whatever I do,
I should feel that a hundred percent
conviction because you really don't know.
And I am an independent for, so
I feel, I don't feel, I mean,
I'm sure I will have
other issues and runnings.
I'm not expecting some bed
roses after this. So, um,
I just feel that whatever it
is, it should be like, you know,
something that I really believe in
100% and I can stake my life on it.
I'm sorry I missed the first 20 minutes.
I'm not sure if you answered it then.
It doesn't matter. We'll answer again.
Yeah. I mean, especially in India,
it's always been the movies that have
been like a major player in perpetuating
stereotypes and stigma or they mostly
just objectify women and the people,
I mean, the general public is also
interested in just commercial movies,
which like how like,
you know,
like two or three songs and they just
want to have a fun time and that's where
all the market is and that's
where all the money is.
So if the film industry is going to
keep doing that, like objectify women,
perpetuate stereotypes,
uh, I mean that, I mean,
for me that looks like the single most
important player in doing all those stuff.
If that's not going to change, do you
think, uh, you know, how, how do you,
how do you see the Bollywood
or like industry moving
towards like, you know, uh,
more, uh, focusing towards
feminism and stuff like that?
I think you're absolutely right.
And I completely agree that,
um, uh, you know,
a lot of the 10 big Bollywood
tentpole kind of films, uh,
they really, uh, I think
mindlessly they keep,
I don't even think that plan is
to necessarily perpetuate, uh,
the objectification of women. I think
they do or don't even think about it. And,
um, uh, I do think that
it's very important,
particularly if look for a country like
India because I feel the way we portray
love, for instance, talking is
portrayed as love. And I feel like, um,
you know, cinema and other kinds
of popular culture and society,
they just keep feeding off each other
and that's just how it is on the streets.
And that's just like, so you're constantly
reinforcing the idea that, you know,
a guy will go and grab this
woman's arm and he'll be like,
she doesn't even know me. He's like,
I love you. And five scenes later,
rather than calling him out
on his stockish tie behavior,
she's going to be like,
I love you too.
So therefore the idea that is being
propagated is that that's how you,
you know, go out. Uh,
so I do feel that all of it are and
way like the fact that we still have
something,
all the item song of the usage of the
word item for the woman I think is awful.
And the fact that the camera goes up and
down a woman's body when she's randomly
dancing to some strange like double
meaning lyrics like your chicken,
etc. And uh, you know, like it's, uh, and,
and the cameras is going up and down her
body though it has no connection with
the story or anything.
And the fact that people are watching
it and not thinking about it. I,
I feel it's very, very problematic and
it bothers me a lot. I don't, I mean,
I think the only thing we can do is to
continue to ensure that there are more
alternative films out there and hope
that people like come and watch them.
So I think the very encouraging thing
about the release of lipstick and my
worker in, uh, in India was that it
actually did really well commercially.
And people actually came to the
theater to see it and nobody was really
expecting that. So I think,
uh, um, I don't know,
it is a sign of some
sort of, uh, you know,
at least interest in something else.
But I think you're right. It's a very,
very entrenched system. But I guess, uh,
the audience is also like largely
responsible because I feel that, um,
until people don't start
rejecting these films, um,
money's always going to be put into them.
So I think between the audience and the
studios who don't have that much courage
and therefore they keep,
you know,
they feel it's very safe and it's some
money spinner and all of that and they're
not even thinking about
what is being made.
So I feel like actually everybody
has to take like a step forward,
whether it is a writers were right
to continuing to ride these films or
directors are continuing to direct
these films without any kind of like a
critical thought about what it is that
they're sort of doing a, you know,
so I feel the entire system,
whether it's a good geographers,
it's like the literacies everyone.
So I think like it has to,
everyone has to take a step forward.
But I think the biggest steps will
be taken by a need to be taken by the
audience because these films exist
because the audience is watching,
watching them. And I think the
second thing is other studios,
the studios really have to take a call
that these are not the kind of films you
want to, uh, promote. Yeah.
But we have to keep fighting because
otherwise like there's no future.
So how practical do you think,
um,
it is for women to put
herself first write down?
Do you think the society and the family
will understand that she's doing this
for a reason? Or does she have
to win the battle eventually?
Yeah,
I mean, I guess it's different depending
on who the woman is and in what case.
And it's not,
I mean,
I guess it's very difficult to
all that I'm put yourself first.
But I do think it's time that
women thought of themselves,
not as just the hubs of,
you know,
or just standing behind somebody, but
really about what they want. And that in,
in every aspect of their lives
because I do feel that, uh,
the fulfillment of women as lost on
priority in any kind of a scenario,
you know, it's always,
um, so I don't feel it's,
it's important and I think
we must think about it, uh,
about like the world that we want to
leave behind because I feel if we don't
make that effort,
we are so then like the
generation after us will like,
so I think we are very odd because people
before us Fortive they're taught that
we should not even make the effort
that women are equally integrated into
political life. Like even whether
they have the right to vote.
So then we will be still fighting
for the right to vote, you know,
or the right to like study or whatever.
So I just feel like every generation
needs to take it upon itself to go a step
further so that at least what you look
kind of world that you leave behind for
the next generation there is,
I mean it's a little better.
It can't be that the world I inhabited.
I wouldn't just leave it in the same way.
Like I just feel our
purpose as human beings is,
has got to be more than just existing.
And I do feel,
and that's where I really
feel that. Um, so if you know,
if it's like if I have a niece or nephew
or a younger cousin or a younger sister
because I'm not a mom, but if I
bought a mother and I had a child,
I mean I had a daughter,
surely I would,
it's like the old world learn
by example and even the boys.
So if I create a more equal,
I made that effort of like knowing
what women want is also important.
Then those are the things people,
especially the younger people around us
are going to imbibe and then that's what
they want to live out. So I just feel
like we all have to, I mean, I don't know.
That's how I feel that we all have to
take that one one step because otherwise
there'll be no change and we'll
just be, you know, running,
I mean just standing in the same place.
Okay.
Just wanted to ask a question about
their experiences in the film industry.
You've worked with like a lot of,
a lot of really illustrious people.
I'm just wondering,
uh,
Hsa [inaudible] cognizant
chairman for Catia g.
So like some interesting experiences or
anecdotes you might have to share with
all of us or if any inspiration you've
drawn from them or just anything,
uh, some of your experiences
in the nurse tree. Yeah.
Uh,
so I want to say that I'm a very non
through me kind of person who's looking in
the film industry,
but I do feel it's important to look at
people as people and not look at them in
terms of the major persona
they might come with.
I feel I've learned a lot from Mr Java
cause I've been working with him since I
finished, um, college.
But apart from like the technical skills
at one picks up by working on a set,
I think, um, I think from him, I've
known some major life lessons. Uh,
I think as a filmmaker,
the first thing I think that he really
taught me that it's very important to
have your own voice and whether somebody
gets it or they get it or like it's
harder for you.
You have to figure out who you are and
what you want to see through in the sense
that not that you often has to
have a message, but you have to,
you have to make a film
that is honest to you.
And I think that is something that has
really stayed with me and told me that
before I was making my first film. And
I think that is something that, um,
I really feel it's very,
very important that it's not because
I feel like everyone has different
strengths and every storyteller,
every filmmaker need not the other person.
It's very important to listen to oneself
and figure out what is it that I want
to see and then see it even though knowing
so with me is that I know that I have
chosen a more difficult path,
but I've done in New England because I
know this is what I want to do is what I
feel passionately about.
So think that was one very important
thing that I learned to when the second
thing was of course to have the courage
to see things till the end no matter
what.
And I think that lesson
has also really been,
uh,
a guiding sort of light in my life because
I feel many times I haven't been in a
situation where I think without that,
um,
sense of perseverance I may have given up.
But I think it's also something
I learned very early on, um,
through a lot of my interactions
with him about not, you know, what,
seeing things like senior Phil,
no matter what happens to it,
I'm seeing it through right until the end,
no matter what it takes.
So think those are the two leg really
important things I learned from him.
And I think, um, from Kankana
and a wrap, no, I feel like, uh,
with me,
if I worked with an actor,
I feel once the actor has decided
they're going to work on my film,
it doesn't matter how what
they've done before. Uh,
of course I respect the fact that the
accomplished actors where I feel we're
starting afresh. And I
think what I love about, um,
a flatland gone going number with is that,
uh,
they never came with any kind of baggage
about how great their past has been or
anything. And I think,
uh, um, Yan, they, them,
I didn't have to, like, we did a lot
of preparatory work for the film,
like lots of rehearsals,
workshops, readings, and uh,
wrap nine Concannon did exactly the same
amount of work as the two other girls
in the film were actually new actors.
There was no difference. And, uh,
and I think that is what makes, um, uh,
artists great when they don't have a
sense of arrogance about, you know,
feeling like, oh, I already know it
all. I don't need to put in the effort.
I think it was very,
very clear and everyone puts in a lot
of effort and there was no sense of uh,
um, you know, I'm already on
national award winning actor.
I don't need to do rehearsals for one
month for like shooting for 20 days,
but they all did it. So
I feel like, uh, uh, I,
I think there was that
instinctive sort of, you know,
bonding over that this is how we see the
filament is how we're going to sort of,
uh,
sort of work.
So I feel like for me in the good
learning in that was that, um,
I think for all of us, we
should never become, uh, um,
arrogant our craft
in terms of like nothing
or whiskey booking do.
How can I hone my craft more and how can
I deepen my art more and how can I, um,
yeah, become better and better
at what I do. Thank you.
That's awesome.
Thank you so much for your questions.
So we have like one minute to go.
I do want to ask a final closing question.
What do you want your audience
to take away from this movie?
Hmm.
I think a month's,
a little like what I said about what
the goods like should feel. But yeah,
I just feel like,
um,
I don't believe in this
idea of messaging so much.
So I feel it's a story about for
ordinary women of different ages.
So I actually want people to
just experience their lives, um,
for those two hours and laugh and cry and
smile with them and feel with them and
go back home thinking about them.
Let's think Alan creative for her time.
This has been amazing. Thank you so much.